The classes, that, come with this course, such as the Picture class here, all
have an owner's manual. Here is how you can find it. Select the Tools menu,
Project Documentation. And a browser window will pop up. Here it is. As you can
see, we have the documentation of the Picture class. As you scroll through it,
you will find a method summary. For example, here's the grow method and you can
see it says resizes this picture both horizontally and vertically. When you
click on the link, a detailed explanation pops up. And here it explains that
you need to feed two numbers that are called dw and dh. And they're further
described down here. The first number is the amount by which to re size the
width on each side. and the other the amount by which to re size the height on
each side. That's how it works for the classes that we give you. If you use a
standard library class such as the String class, you instead want to look at
the official documentation. I've made a bookmark for it and I suggest you do
the same. Here it is. On the left, you have a listing of all of the various
classes. They're many of them, most of which you never need to know. Let's find
the String class. Here it is. Click on it. On the right, the documentation for
the String class is displayed and again, you can scroll through it. You will
find a summary of all of the methods. There are many methods, most of which you
don't need to know, and when there's one that interests you, you can click on
it and get a detailed explanation. You will have lots of practice with that
during this lesson.